[Music]
but how do you feel about your fit like
oh i think i look good it's like pizza
it's like bad but you know it's still
good
[Music]
oh shoot hold up you guys are very good
by the way just wants to tell you all
don't even start now uh-uh okay
someone's gonna have to be last so i
don't wanna
so how do you feel about the suit is
that one three five i feel like it sits
in the middle for me personally just
because it's like it's
it's like it's like a safe move okay i
think when it comes to style like the
intention is what's the most important
part
the cuffs on the on the shirt over there
i like how you rolled that up this is
just super interesting and different but
like can you
put intention yeah you should be top
top three without a doubt i came today
because i was like i like wanna put on
like my best outfit and
i feel i feel happy and i feel good in
my outfit
i feel the most me when i'm fully
dressed up it's just like
an expression of how i feel on the
inside on the outside
should we rank how we would go between
all of us
kind of see where the average comes out
so like yeah okay okay
i feel confident in my outfit so i feel
best dressed
there you go um um it looks very fresh
looks very sharp
so second this jacket is such a
statement
yeah that's a nice jacket and then
between you two
i really like how clean your shoes look
like the
the mix of the green with the little bit
of navy blue on the bottom
i like the color so forth and then you
fit i'll take that
so i'm gonna take the one spot for
myself two
because the shoes are dope you put a lot
of intention into how you got to
together today i can tell the only thing
i might not mix the two sports together
oh
okay like you know baseball and football
together that's kind of like
personally personal you know what i get
it three
like just because you came to play today
i can tell thank you and i appreciate it
i
definitely would never wear something
like that but i can't knock
how confident you have to be to put that
on you know that's
that's admirable four or five the only
thing for me is like you've got work
wear vibes up top
and then like dope shoes on the bottom
and it just doesn't really necessarily
mesh for me
i would hope that people like notice the
little accents i probably didn't do
exactly what i wanted to in regards to
maybe jewelry
or like maybe even shoe choice okay sean
would definitely be first because you
definitely came
with that intention and you could tell
so you're gonna stay at one
being that you have a suit like you kind
of already topped everybody and you knew
that
so i'm gonna just keep you at two keep
myself at three you guys are
interchangeable
you guys are both kind of in the same
vibe i like your hat because it says
bastard on it
i would just just stay in this order
honestly
yeah for me i'm only ranking and based
off of like what i would wear
i guess it just makes sense for me i'll
say one honestly just because
just just levels yo i'ma put myself at
two just because i do like
my own style a lot to keep it real i
would say three because i'm sticking
with my thing
about the suit the suit looks good but
it's like it's a suit zara
probably could cop one four and five all
right yeah
okay we'll go with one two i'm gonna go
for three
i appreciate the suit you know like a
james bond type of dude
[Laughter]
number four correct there we go uh i put
you there just because
i feel like i look too tall i'd be like
seven i'd be like
so you're picturing yourself and
everybody's out exactly yeah that's how
i'm putting myself where you guys are
i rank myself at number five just
because uh i still feel confident at
being number five you can't keep
yourself at five i like being here
it's not it's like it's kind of like
this well you know you guys you're
enlightened
yeah but how do you feel about your fit
personally oh i think i look good
i look kind of sexy but like not kind of
like in a weird way it's like it's like
pizza it's like bad
but you know it's still good that's what
i really like
being younger i used to be super
insecure because uh i used to
look like a like a circle and uh
it didn't make me feel super good
clothing was an outlet of
a way that i could appear better so is
this the order we're gonna put ourselves
this is it this is what we
is we're saying we're averaged out i
feel totally cool i mean i think this is
a solid average i think everybody
looks good so it is what it is
can you put on your earmuffs
[Music]
okay ladies let's go personally i feel
like
anyone can wear a suit i'll probably
move them to like a
three when i think of best dress and i
think of a male like suit is the first
thing that comes to mind so i think
maybe it would have been
a little bit cooler for him to step
outside of the box i mean you're free to
have that i
i would put him at one but that's just
my style that's what i like
i feel like he probably like blows those
with cigars
like giving me like a very like
expensive vibe i'm a fan of the blue and
the brown
he has his belt to match his shoes to me
that's very important so just the detail
that he put into it it's not like i just
threw on a suit like how he said there
is intent they're intent in
putting on the outfit i want to say two
two three two or three
okay but like how do we feel about
number one right now
i think i'm looking more for what i'm
drawn to and i'm personally just not
drawn to it i really respect his choices
it's just not for me personally for me
practicality and fashion are so
interlinked
honestly i think i'm just drawn to
traditional things and
it was a little bit too avant-garde for
me i would probably
put him at four okay can't relate that's
okay
go for it why do i can't really i
feel like shawn just has i mean he has
the second best outfit in the room
you know but like it's just all around
such a cohesive look
have you seen his makeup too oh the red
eyeliner gorgeous go off gorgeous
it takes like confidence to go out and
wear what you want to wear
so i really like him being number one
personally i like when
guys wear stuff because it represents
them and not because it's like trending
or name brand yeah i think he deserves
number one flower is number one red hat
should be number two okay
i like that he color coordinated like i
know they said something about like
sports like mismatching i wouldn't have
noticed that i noticed the sports um
that's just me i don't really like to
cross brands either unless it's probably
like luxury that that's just a hit but
if i'm wearing adidas i won't wear nike
i really like green shirts green shirt
you know that sounds forced i felt like
i could just go up and talk to him
and he was well dressed but i wasn't
intimidated by him which i think is a
very fine line in fashion can we just
like notice his accessories can i see
your hands
look at his rings
i love rings they're so cute i think i
think green shirts one for me
they mentioned that they felt a little
sexy i see that they're giving me
cleavage like it's it's cute
and then brown shirt i like the shoes i
like the accent um the little red accent
on the shoes i'm not noticing that
i don't know if i'd ever wear that hat
but i think it's definitely makes a
statement and it's worth talking about
i feel like he's giving me a lot of very
runway streetwear vibes
and i really love how versatile his look
is so he would be number two for me
all right so how are we going to
rearrange them we all clearly have
different like interpretations of like
what we would wear obviously just being
on the line
for me a little bit less is more so i
think because it's so basic
green shirt gave us all those
accessories it was like okay i'm gonna
give you guys like my best everyday fit
green shirt to the front we think green
shirts all the way at the front
i mean he's either one or two i think
two two okay two
okay but we agree that shawn is number
one and sean can stay there
the flowers could stay there okay cool
what about red hat as
five how do we feel about i think i
think that's good
it's close i don't agree i think you
know obviously
i think red hat should be number three
in this you want to put suit at number
four
i just like
[Music]
girl all my friends are drag queens and
i'm gay so i'm not really
too in immense fashion take my advice
with a grain of salt
i think that like the suit is better
than red hat
so i probably keep them there okay so
let's just decide between four and five
i don't know i still say switch up to
five i don't know
i feel like i've just seen red hat to
five yeah i say red hat to five yeah i
would switch them personally so yeah
switch them off and then
you guys switch
it's kind of like a good medium yeah
between everybody yeah for sure
yeah i think this is pretty they
convinced me the fit is everything so
yeah
i got up here that was a pretty
interesting i didn't
think i'd be up here actually hey hey i
was shocked too but
i was not shocked that shawn stayed at
one yeah i was not shocked
at all i don't necessarily think sean
was the best dress i just think
he just made the biggest statement i put
a lot of thought into my outfit i'd like
tried to coordinate the clips
and i even got my nails done to like
match
the flowers i thought about like every
single detail so maybe
they noticed that and i'm glad that they
did i thought the shoes were gonna push
me up
honestly i thought these shoes were
gonna do i put them on today i say yeah
at least two you know just because you
put a lot of intention behind it
sometimes it doesn't get
noticed in the ways that you think i
think they thought a suit was a safe
bet and that i didn't take too much too
much risk where in my mind i feel like i
took
quite a bit of risk wearing like the
patterned suit and you know the
the bolder type fit and maybe a tighter
fit my style
is just like work wear but make it sexy
like that's kind of my thing
you know it's not for everybody but i
feel mad comfy i'm ready for work i'm
ready for
a cool little day date we could go for a
little picnic or something sometimes i
get a lot of like hate comments
or some people are like confused like
hey you're a guy like why are you
wearing a skirt
i'm perfectly fine with being who i am
at the end of the day
it's about you and about like what makes
you happy